well this is a pleasure to be here but
before I start I want to acknowledge
that the three of us wouldn't be here at
all if it weren't for people who were in
the LIGO laboratory in the LIGO
scientific collaboration and in the
Virgo collaboration and the Virgo
experiment and since some of you are
here I'm going to insist that you stand
up would you please do that
[Applause]
[Music]
they're really the reason we're here and
now we're the three of us are gonna give
a talk which on the surface looks the
same
you saw the titles like oh and sign and
gravitational waves I'll give you a
little preview it's and we won't really
may be able to hold in this preview
exactly I'll talk about the old times
and the oldest and and very we'll talk
about the present and Kipp will talk
about the future now it's not gonna go
quite that way and we will intermingle
the times so don't forgive us but that's
the basic structure so let me start by
those of you and who don't really know
much about gravitational waves and
gravity this is mostly a little bit of a
pedagogical thing in the beginning as
most of you were trained in in high
school and possibly in college is you
learnt about Newton's theory of gravity
which is a theory in which there are
forces that between masses and that
force gets smaller the bigger the
distance between the masses and it is a
wonderful theory it does almost all you
need in fact it got the space program
working there's nothing terribly wrong
with that theory but it isn't right okay
and Einstein saw this pretty quickly
after he developed a special theory of
relativity it doesn't have a way in it
of dealing with very large masses moving
at high velocities that's not in in in a
Newton's theory at all and nor does it
have a way of communicating information
in the gravitational field from one
place to the other for example if the
Sun disappeared and we know it takes
about nine minutes for us to see that it
also should take something like nine
minutes for us to find out ravva tation
aliy that it has something has happened
to it and that's something that again
was not in in the Newton theory and so
this picture which is hardly complete
but is of some way to imagine this new
theory that Einstein developed is if you
imagine a jungle gym a big assembly that
you played in as kids in New York where
I was there were lots of those and you
take a cut through it and you have laid
out all those ball
and you've done one more thing which
isn't something you did when you were a
kid you laid clocks out on every
intersection point all along here you
put clocks everywhere and what the
Einstein theory says is what this
picture is trying to show if you take a
cut through it there will be when you're
far away from the Sun that's the Sun and
when you're far away from the earth when
you're far away from those let's say out
here space itself looks very Euclidean
it looks the same way as in Jungle Jim
did but and the clocks that are running
on all those intersection points they
all read the same time but as you walk
toward the Sun in this plane you'll
notice that the distortion in space you
don't see the distortion in time because
I didn't put you clocks there but the
clocks in here are running a little more
slowly than the clocks out there and a
little bit of that also happens that the
earth is a little dimple that the earth
does and the way John Wheeler explained
Einstein's theory he says matter
distorts space and time and then matter
moves because of the distortion in space
and time and that's the best I can do
for you people do better okay and in
that theory there is also gravitational
waves and I want to show you first a
gravitational wave the and the
gravitational waves move at the speed of
light you've heard that already and but
there they are as you'll see in a minute
and what's this picture will show is
there a transverse wave there a wave
that distorts space perpendicular to the
direction in which the wave moves and so
let me turn on this little animation but
before I do that before you because
you'll get sick looking at it there you
are right there that's you in that
little red square and now I'll turn on
the sound and animation so you can see
the wave coming by you and you'll see
some patterns in this which are
important for understanding how we
detected these things first of all
you'll notice that in let's say the
horizontal direction and let's say it's
expanding but in the vertical direction
is contracting now any one moment these
things will flip but will they there
will be opposite motions vertically and
horizontally that's one thing so that's
a pattern that you you exploit by the
way you'll see where how we exploit that
the other thing about
is that that these are the objects that
you threw out into the space as the
gravitational wave comes through I
should have told you that so you look
here with not near you these let's say
these little masses they don't move very
much but the masses that are far away
from you they move a lot and that's a
picture of a constant strain along at
any one moment the change in distance
between objects is proportional to their
separation and that change in distance
divided by the separation is called the
strain and we will talk about that a lot
that's the quantity we measure while we
actually measure the distance
separations but the quantity you
described as the field quantity in the
theory is the strain and so let me tell
you a little bit of history now we
talked already about this theory being
developed about a hundred years ago in
1915 Einstein gave the world the general
theory of relativity is which was
described somewhat by that first picture
but then in 1916 he wrote a paper and I
have to drink something just to bear
with me it's not forever in that theory
yeah later on he had a paper in 1916
where he describes a lot of things that
showed that it had a Newtonian limit and
he also shows that there are
gravitational waves in that 1916 paper
and the only reason why I bring this up
here is because of a very interesting
statement he made at the very end of the
paper he's described these things now to
talk to them about them in a minute but
he describes an equation which is up
here I will only tell you what that is
it says this is the strength of gravity
with gravitational waves and this is a
source of gravitational waves
oscillations and accelerations of matter
and he says something extremely
interesting
I haven't here in German but I'll read
it to you in English in any case one can
think of a that quantity will have a
practically vanishing value this is at
the end of that paper since you'll never
be able to measure this it's of no
consequence to science that's
effectively what he was saying and then
so he makes a mistake in this paper but
that has nothing to do with it in 1918
he corrects that but I want to be I'll
be presumptive
a little bit and we have I've asked the
people who will have the Antonine papers
to try to find what I'm about to show
you and they haven't found this on the
back of an envelope or in his notebooks
but I'm sure it's there somewhere
so let's I'm trying to give you a little
feel for why he made that statement and
you have to put yourself in the context
of 1915 1916 what did people know about
and what did they have and the first
thing you might have thought about is
two trains colliding how much
gravitational waves come out of that and
so let me give you I will use this is
not oh it's the only formula but I'll
explain it to you okay so here's the
strain that's H and this is the quantity
that when you want to estimate how much
strain you get from some kind of motion
is the a very simple estimation formula
it has the Newtonian constants in it the
mass of the objects and the distance
you're away from them and the velocity
of light squared that quantity GM
divided by RC squared is a very
important dimensionless quantity that we
all know and love what it is on the
earth right here it's about 10 to the
minus 10 it's very small you live in an
extremely small gravitational field even
though you may have to have knee
operations okay but on the other hand
what you'll hear about from Barry and
Kip is the places where this number is
closer to 1 it's huge
and those are places where now round
black holes and other places the
beginning of the universe and so forth
and the other quantity is V squared over
C squared this sort of a measure of how
much motion there is and that's velocity
divided the velocity of the object
divided by the velocity of light squared
so that quantity allows you to estimate
H so here for example for the two trains
coming together and by the way trains in
the United States don't go much faster
than this nowadays that that has not
been much advanced than that maybe in
Europe but not here not not in the
United States so let's pick 10 to the 5
kilograms but for the mass the velocity
about 100 killer kilometers per hour a
collision time of a third of seconds or
so yeah and you have to be far enough
away so you're not looking at Newtonian
just a new induced field you have to go
far away
enough so that you're looking at the
radiation field the field that carries
these waves so you have to go out a
wavelength about that's 300 kilometers
and the H value you get is 10 to the
minus 42 and that is truly impossible we
can't even do that now and that's why
Einstein probably made that statement so
he might have went very well looked at
something else I mean he knew about the
Stars and he knew about binary stars and
these people may not may did not know
about the galaxies the galaxies was
something I was being discovered at the
time and so but suppose he put numbers
into that and he takes stars that are
going around each other once once a day
here the two stars and suppose there are
a distance of about 10,000 light-years
away they might have guessed at that it
might have been 30 he probably didn't
know exact number for the size of the
galaxy because you really didn't know
about it and you get an H value which
isn't pretty small it's 10 to minus 23
with a period of half a day every half
and every half a day happily takes less
every half day you go through a thing
that looks the same so you get you look
for gravitational waves with a period of
half a day with a strength of 10 to
minus 23 that's what we would do now but
in his day he would have said well how
much energy is being taken away by
gravitational waves I'm not gonna
describe that formula but if you look at
it that's what that gives and you would
get something like the following I'll
just say what the end result is here you
would have gotten that it would take 10
to the 13 years there 10 to the 13 years
for those stars in a telescope to look
like they were changing their business
their separation it's clearly hopeless
and so in both ways as an astronomical
thing and it's a technical thing I can
completely understand that Einstein now
it turns out in our epoch finally there
was a situation where that experiment
that I just described to you or the
measurement I just described you was
actually done but was done fairly
quickly and this is sort of the hundred
years later the technology has changed
and what we know about astronomy has
changed and this all becomes possible
and the thing is these are these are
Nobel Prize winners these two
rustle halts who was a graduate student
at the time and Joe Taylor and these
were they they both were the University
of Massachusetts at the time there but
they went to Princeton went because this
was a major discovery and I got scooped
up by all these wonderful places and
what they discovered was a system of
they didn't know it but they discovered
a pulsar
they were looking with a radio telescope
they looked and they used the Arecibo
telescope in fact the one that got in
the trouble in the big hurricane and and
they they listened and they heard a
thing going like that and it was going
in about 17 times a second that's the
pulsar and these are neutron stars stars
made completely of neutrons and they are
but they have the mass of the Sun and
they're about the size of Stockholm it's
really unbelievably dense thing and what
they heard is the pulse is coming from
that but they weren't going at a regular
rate sometimes I'm going a little faster
sometimes they're going a little slower
and it turns out when they map this they
kept looking at it they found that for
about four hours and this is the model
of it it turns out it turns out to be a
pair of neutron stars and they're going
around each other and when this pulsar
which is sending its pulses to the radio
telescope is moving toward the earth
which is over here it goes a little
faster from the Doppler effect and when
it's moving away from the earth it goes
a little slower and that's what we saw
and they map that and they watched it
through many many years this is time
over here and they saw in 1973 and they
kept watching it and what they noticed
is all sorts of all the wonderful tests
and general relativity were done by that
system but the one that was most telling
and most interesting for us today is
this one it's the one where they plot
the length of time it takes for the
orbit to complete every time you go
around once it's a period of the orbit
it's being plotted here this is in time
epoch of the blocking the system and
this is the period of the orbit getting
shorter and shorter and shorter
these are minus signs over here and not
the dots that are in here are their
measurements and the line that goes
through them is the prediction from the
1918 paper with a factor of two
correction that Einstein made of how
that system should lose energy due to
gravitational weight
so that was the very first indirect
measurement but the first measurement of
gravitational waves really profound
thing and it won a Nobel Prize okay so
then the next thing that happened and
this is again it happened because of
technology changes and what happened
people began to have the fact that you
could think of these very small strains
and you now had equipment as the
technology change where you could think
of making a measurement and the first
person who actually thought of that was
Joe Weber he's right here
he was a professor at the University of
Maryland that's him and there he is with
his invention the invention was by the
way also invention made together with
John Wheeler who was Kip's thesis
supervisor okay and what it is is a
great big bar it's like a monster suit
you can see how big it is it's a big is
a man maybe bigger and what Joe was
hoping will happen is that a
gravitational wave will go through this
thing stretch it momentarily and leave
it and leave it singing much like you
hit it with a hammer and there he is
attaching little strain gauges to the
device so he can hear that he was a
electronic equipment that was becoming
available and what happened is to his
misfortune he saw something and in fact
he saw something he made he made several
of these and put them in different
places in the United States he invented
the idea of using coincidence methods to
do this and he saw he had a system like
this in Chicago in the middle of the
United States one in Maryland and none
of them eight miles away from his office
in a golf course in Maryland also and
they saw he saw coincident pulses and in
1969 he published the paper which said
he had discovered gravitational waves
and it turns out that many many other
people became interested in doing that
and science that's what always happens a
stunning result like this can be tested
by everybody else and to his misfortune
nobody else saw these waves nobody else
saw these pulses and now we know why
people didn't see the pulses the
strength will fall and this is something
useful to remember
the strength that you need and he was
able to measure with these things a
strain of about 10 to the minus 15 six
orders of magnitude bigger than what
ultimately you needed okay I'm sorry
okay
I didn't realize that was happening so
what happened is people began to think
of other methods of doing this and one
method of doing it I'll describe here is
not with a bar but rather with a thing
which you really in the end was more
successful in making the real
measurements and that is to look at
three masses but like that picture of
the gravitational wave a mass over here
and you put another mass over there a
goodly distance away and you take and
measure the time it takes you want to
measure their separation as changing as
the gravitational wave comes by that
same picture of all those dots that I
showed you and so the idea is really
simple you take and have a light send
that and put a clock on those month put
clocks on the masses or we actually
let's start that way clock here clock
there on those masses send light
measured the moment when the light left
this mass and find out with another
clock over here the time when it hits
that mass that's the way of measuring
the distance between those two masses
and then let the thing unfold and as a
gravitational wave comes along it'll
change that time because it's changing
that distance it's as simple as that now
if you here's the idea and this is a way
which a key almost works and you don't
you here you have a laser and the beam
splitter which is a device that splits
the light and that's as in the picture I
showed you that would be the red square
that I showed you here is a distant mass
and that's a mirror and there's another
distant mass and remember the
gravitational wave is coming down and
what it'll do is it'll stretch one of
these and compress this and it will flip
then this one will stretch and that one
will compress and here is the way you
make that measurement which is
effectively timing light so with us but
I'll describe as it goes along where
it's red is light and we're thinking of
red lasers when they made this picture
but what you see is the waves these
actual waves inside the power of the
light and where it's red is where
there's light if you do it right and
make the time here equal to the time of
light there you get no light going to
the photo detector that's the idea and
so if you will show that's for the
photos it's like now when you move these
masses one out the other one in you'll
see that there is light when the motion
makes it so the path links are no longer
equal and that is in fact the basis for
the entire experiment because it's no
more complicated than that
the big problem comes you have to do it
extremely well and here is how well kick
comes on the scene I met Kip in 1975
when he and I met in Washington DC he
was thinking at that time he was giving
testimony to a committee and he and I
spent the night talking about what kind
of experiments are interesting to do and
he was at that time had already the most
successful group I think in the country
doing theoretical gravitation and he was
hoping to start a group at Caltech start
a group in in in experimental work and
what we came on is that Kip at that
meeting he you know I talked about that
ultimately there's this technique that
we were just talking about here would be
a good thing for Caltech to work on and
but he told us something then already
that you couldn't just do it in this
haphazard way that was it had to be done
and he was one of the first to tell us
that if you want to get in the business
you had to measure H's or these strains
Delta changes in length divided by the
length of 10 to the minus 21 I think
this is Kip about that time he'll tell
us if I'm wrong yeah he's good he's
agreeing okay and big thing is that if
you make something and now we're getting
on mixing times but that's too bad
suppose if you go to something as long
as four kilometers you then and you do
the a little bit of arithmetic that's
associated with that you find out that
you have to measure distances at the
ends that motion of 10 to the minus 18
meters that's something like a
thousandth the size of a nucleus of an
atom that's very hard
here is the challenge that this threw at
us if you want to use light to make that
measurement light has a wavelength of
about 10 to the minus 6 meters you have
to go a million times times a million
million times a million more sensitive
into the wavelength of light to get into
business that's what he was telling us
if you want to use light to do this but
then you had another problem which an
nhien turned out to be much harder than
that problem and that is even though you
might have made a wonderful measure
method of measuring things their
position with light the things that
you're looking at I'm not going to be
standing still well they're gonna be
kicked around by everything in the world
especially the world and because you and
I are sitting right here where we're
being jiggled around by the ground by
about one micron
at least a few microns so 10 minus 6 so
he got another factor of a million times
a million and that one was a really hard
one and so here is the things that went
on and now the rest of this is really
about people because people are critical
to getting that factor of a billion and
a billion building us a pile European
billion ten is six times in this second
so a guy who really helped a lot in this
thing was a guy named who was not so
heralded it's a man named Pirani who was
a theorist who told us yes it was
possible to measure gravitational waves
with things freely floating around that
was a big big challenge there was a lot
of worry about whether you could ever
extract any kind of measurable signal
from gravitational waves and he showed
us that there was an invariant way
didn't depend on the coordinates that
you use of showing that a gravitational
wave was mood was moving the masses
changing his face and that's of course
exploited in this and several ideas and
these are all people who were critical
to it some of the gimmicks some of the
tricks that you need and some of the
tricks were first exploited in a small
prototype at MIT but it was not a very
good prototype but the ideas I won't
describe that picture anymore to say the
following thing we knew already that God
used lasers you couldn't use just one a
very weak light source
the other thing you needed to is you're
somehow allowed to make the light go
more than once back and forth you have
to bounce the light back and forth and
you had to do tricks to get around the
noise and there were tricks you have to
modulate the light you have to use all
the cunning tricks yeah and the other
thing you had to do is you couldn't put
the masses right on the ground
you had to somehow float them so the
ground and motion would not make a
single so large that you couldn't see
the gravitational waves and all those
tricks were tried in this prototype but
the people who really did it right and
who actually demonstrated to all of us
that this was possible was the group
that's up on top here and you'll notice
that this is the group that was in gaja
ng a max planck group and here is Heinz
Billings he was a guy who worked on bars
with Weber was severely disappointed the
whole group after they did it they
showed they were one of the first and
most accurate to show that where his
experiments were not right and so they
were fishing around what would be the
next thing to do and instead of quitting
they decided they were gonna go into
this in a fair metric method of doing
this and here they are and each one of
them the one who's in the room here is
Albert reader
he's somewhere in this room I haven't
seen him but unfortunately there most of
them are dead the bath of inker is still
alive and coughs nope and we have
celebrated her her name is now ingrained
in the apparatuses we have for a
particular trick of making it so you can
see the fringes better my Vega was
deeply involved in that hanging all the
masses not just the mirrors hanging
everything we didn't think of that
just hang everything get the hell with
it learn how to do interferometry with
things that aren't suspensions forget
about it how difficult it is and the
same thing with a read ago he was also
advocating that and he is a role on
Schilling who invented all sorts of
ideas of how to get the event how to get
toward that factor of 10 to the 12 in in
insensitivity he also invented along
with Ron River we'll talk about in a
minute the idea of power recycling so
then there was another group so they
were what what did they do we will talk
about a little more but they built a
three meter prototype much faster than
the people in MIT did and they showed
that a lot of the ideas were right they
also showed that a lot of the things
thinking that had been done ahead of
that had mistakes in it that we hadn't
thought it through properly which was
very important especially the scattering
light scattering as something they
discovered well here's the other group
that was very important in this
development is the group at Glasgow and
here's Ron driver Ron driver was then
later came to Caltech and worked there
and we'll talk a little about that in a
minute but Jim Hoff was his student and
here's Brian Mears invented a very a
critical idea that has now become
important in these interferometers did I
not we'll get to that in a minute
but to add another mirror in a very
unlikely place and Harry Ward developed
the ideas of how one might align systems
like this and that group was all at the
beginning they invented a whole bunch of
new ideas also and that group is
critical in this business of going to
the 10 to the 12 in the position
sensitivity and the things that actually
then followed this were instruments they
made more prototypes were built Caltech
when Ron griever went to Caltech and
Stan Whitcomb was hired what happened
they built this instrument I wish I had
more pictures of it and more of the
pictures of people but they built this
40 meter instrument and that's still
operating that 40 meter instrument was a
testbed for the things that went into
the LIGO into the actual legal and here
is a other experiment that was done by
the German group and the German group
with David shoemaker who was had an
import from the United States at the
time and they did they built a 30 after
they got done with their three meter
prototype they built the 30 meter 12 30
metre prototype and showed that the
scaling laws worked
I was absolutely critical and they then
in fact make a lovely statement in here
at the end you can't read this but I'll
tell you they got to the past the
sensitivity of the bars the best bars
they did better with this instrument
then you could do with rubber bars and
that was extremely important statement
because that made everybody say aha
this is the wave of the future and if
you're now gonna build something big
you're gonna have to do it with this car
something that's gonna detect this kind
of thing here's the group at MIT it a
little later reason why I'd like this is
because it has some of the people who
are now leaders of this thing and there
there were young people they
nergis mavala love of allah and then
there's there's the this Peters Mitchell
right there and in the back is Brian
Brian Lantz
and this is Mike zuker who was at
Caltech working on the 40 meter he came
to an MIT this was after a while it
turned out those two groups became sort
of completely interchangeable and that
was a lot of things were done there I
won't go into all of them all
preparatory to what I'm about to show
you so this is out of time science it
should really belong in Barry's talk but
I have to show it because he wants to
show other things too this is actually
the interferometer that Accu made the
detection and let me I'm not gonna walk
you through except to show you where
some of the things you already know
exist
here's the laser again there's the beam
splitter
here's that distant mirror and there's
that distant mirror here's the
gravitational wave coming down the
things that have been added to it are
these two masses this one and that one
that make it so that this becomes
something called a fabry-perot cavity
it's a way effectively bouncing the
light back and forth about 300 times and
in here about 300 times and then here is
the photo detector and again you operate
it in such a manner that there no light
goes to the photo detector when there's
no gravitational wave and then here's
the idea that both Ronde River and
Schilling had you put another mirror
which you haven't seen before between
the laser and the beam splitter and what
that mirror does I will just describe
what it does and I'll show you is it
takes the light that isn't going to the
photo detector that comes out of laser
goes into your arm is not going to the
voter detector it would normally go back
to the laser but you make it so you've
bounced it back into the end of the
interferometer and build up the light
inside the interferometer for that
reason and that makes it as though you
had a very much more powerful laser a
very clever idea then here's Brian Mears
idea and that is that you've put another
mirror which is not this is not
immediately something that everybody can
capture because you need to know a lot
more than I told you why this works so
well but what does it do by putting a
mirror between the detector and the beam
splitter it makes it so you can tailor
the response of the interferometer you
can make it have different shapes make
it have so that it's more sensitive at
certain frequencies and stuff like that
and that's called this is called a power
recycling mirror and that's called a
signal recycling mirror and that's an
important part of advanced LIGO so this
is the advanced LIGO detector okay now
that's the technology other of the how
do you make the light get that factor of
10 to the 12 we're not quite done with
the technology of how you make them
ground motion small enough but first
let's talk about how you build build up
and begin to build up the idea that you
don't want to do just prototypes you
would like to actually build a detector
and that happened in about 1988 II know
that we began to think hard about how
might how expensive how might you build
a system that actually could detect
something we were driven to that for
many many reasons it was hard for
students to at least at MIT to keep
working on something which didn't have a
physics result had had only an
engineering result and I don't know it
Caltech it was different they had a
different attitude about this but the
thing is that what we began to think
about is really we asked the NSF if we
could do and we were also encouraged by
the NSF and we'll get to that at the
very end to make an industrial study
with industry to find out where could
you place a thing that was big enough
and we thought of five kilometer ha arms
maybe even 10 kilometer arms and could
you get the lasers and how would you
make the vacuum system and all the stuff
that goes on that if you want to convert
a thing on a tabletop into something
very big and there was a study done and
I thought to people here were quite
central to this Peter Slauson who helped
in that he was a postdoc would come from
Princeton and Stan Whitcomb who had been
brought on by Caltech and he want to be
part of this same study and this is
called the Blue Book study and it did it
did that a little bit later and with
very significant differences because
during that time between 1983 and 1989
we did a bad thing we had Rhonda River
and Ray Weiss trying to run a big
project with the help of Kip Thorne it
was hopeless and it was noticed by a
committee that met in 1986 that had been
asked to look at this whole field and
that committee had been started by
Richard Garwin a very significant
personage in American science who said
look if you're gonna persist with this
you better have a summer study and that
summer study said look it's a wonderful
experiment
don't hold back build two of them make
them on the long length they said
everything right and they said you can't
do it with that crazy bunch we're
running it okay and said get yourself
director so we got a director and that
director was Robby vote and Robby vote
guided us through writing a proposal
which was really a textbook it's a
beautiful proposal it cost us a lot of
time it's a first real document that
showed a lot of the techniques and how
it might build this and costed it
properly and what happened is that that
proposal became a joint proposal of
Caltech and MIT and there's one very
elegant thing that Farabi vote did among
others he did something which was he
coupled in the process of thinking about
this project
he coupled an engineer if we had an
engineer and we didn't have enough of
them and Barry later when he took this
over realized that but we had some
engineers but we had a lot of scientists
and the idea was couple and engineer who
knew how to count money but also knew
how what was practical with a mad
scientist who want to make sure you
didn't compromise the experiment and
couple them together so that they
designed something and estimated
something which was going to be both
realistic as well as you're able to do
the experiment and that was a very good
experience I can show you only some of
the people here who were in the who did
this and they well you recognize
something there's Ron there's Kip and
then there's a chief engineer at the
time Bill Altos here is an engineer who
stayed with the project and then I
couldn't get a picture of the vacuum
engineer at the time who was doing this
and that is bowed more and here's Larry
Jones and Larry Jones was tagged with me
and we helped design
the big the big beam tubes and so forth
and so this was a very important moment
in the history of like oh let me go
quickly more back to the science a
little bit or the technology and that is
this is the kind of thing that evolved
when in that proposal we want to show
people what limited the performance of a
gravitational wave detector this is in
fact a plot of the things that limited
the verse first detector very will show
you the evolution of that detector but I
just want to walk you through some of
the things in here which are still
important what this is is frequency in
other words this 1 Hertz 100 Hertz
that's an important region 10 kilohertz
over here here is a strain of about 10
to the minus 23 per bandwidth I'm sorry
this is a dig you using here you're
using spectra so if you want to go back
to what I was telling you you have to
multiply this number by the square root
of the frequency that's a detail for
those of you who want to follow but
that's not important what I want to show
you is what was limiting this detector
at high frequencies if this line and
that's the amount of light power you had
at low frequencies it was limited by
something else but I want to continue
this because this is important for kips
talk this is part of what's called the
quantum limit the amount of light you
use to tell the position of the mass is
if you use more light here having more
photons you can bring that down but you
pay a price for that over here is
another piece of that same noise which
is called the radiation pressure and
that is if you use more light
you push on the masses and there's noise
in that light that pushes the masses
around and many of you have led quantum
mechanics know that this something
called the Heisenberg microscope this is
just the Heisenberg microscope
macroscopic okay when you try to measure
better the position of something you
impart more noise momentum to it and
that's what these this curve says and
this is something we're now battling and
you'll hear more about that from Kipp
and from Barry the other noises in this
thing are for example how well can you
get rid of the ground noise and at the
time when we were designing this this
limit is the noise that shakes the
ground
there's seismic noise and that makes a
limited low frequencies
and then there's here this limit is the
fact that everything is a room
temperature and when everything is at
room temperature every surface is
shaking new to phonons since sound waves
in the sound waves that are generated by
the just the fact that there's there's
an energy in the in the tech in the heat
so that's thermal noise and here are
some things that still plague us here is
the thing that made it cost so much
money if you had a vacuum and was only
as good as a certain value and say this
is a value that you could get moderately
easily that would be a limit for a
detector that would be better than this
and I have failed to tell you something
that proposal in 1989 proposed a
two-stage procedure
it's proposed we build one that we know
how to build now or almost know how to
build now and another one we hope to
build in the future and that would need
much better vacuum than this and back
down here and that getting that whole
assembly together making the vacuum good
enough was an expensive proposition but
we have we succeeded with that in a very
unique and interesting way and so what
remains as the noise is this one right
here this is very important nose and
that's the last thing I'll show you in
this picture
you'll notice it gets worse and worse
and worse the lower the frequency and
that is a noise which we have to contend
with and it's the noise that we will
compact to continue to contend with with
as there are two noises in this we have
to continue to candidate this is one of
them and the other one is the one I
already told you about which is the
quantum noise but this one is something
which is not easily thought about always
by people you have the ground shaking
and that's fine but when the ground
shakes there's another piece associated
with that there a wave traveling in the
ground causes the density of the ground
to change and let's say this bunch of
flowers is the mirror and here are these
waves coming by and as it as it moves
here's this compression going on in the
ground like that and as the compression
goes by this it's a little higher
density over here that pulls the flowers
over to the sit to the ground that's a
force on the mirror that's plain
Newtonian gravity and that's the noise
waves are their acceleration there but
the density changes in the ground make a
change in the force on the mirror and we
to contend with that and also the
density changes in the atmosphere and
there's the Hungarian - group that has
joined LIGO has think of thought about
methods of measuring the barometric
pressure of carefully enough so that you
can measure that so those are noises
that are still with us and we have to
learn how to get around them and that's
one of the reasons why people propose
the Lisa experiment which Kipp will talk
well I think yeah Kipp will talk about
so all right that's sort of a little
grad quick guide through all the things
that contaminate the gravitational wave
signal the last thing I want to quickly
say and this is Vivian Barry's part of
this presentation that says is what we
did to make the final steps in getting
rid of the ground noise not the gravity
gradient noise but just the acceleration
and this was a contribution to LIGO for
advanced LIGO done by the group in
scotland and this is a as well this is a
very elegant suspension here's spring
that's attached to the ground and
there's a mass and this is a suspension
and a few wiggler suspension quickly
that you hang it the thing you hang it
from doesn't move so you do that once
then you do it once again you do it once
again you do it four times and here's
that very precious mirror that's gonna
be reflecting the light and that four
stage suspension is a critical part of
LIGO and especially a critical part that
we made a detection but even more
important as far as I'm concerned is
this thing which is much too complicated
to tell you about but I'll tell you what
it does it's an active system that gets
rid of the ground noise and you have a
lot of experience with that in in your
hearing I don't know how many of you use
these noise-canceling headphones I'm
sure that people here yeah okay it's the
same principle what you do is you put a
very sensitive seismometer on a platform
and measure the motion of the platform
and then what you do is you push on that
platform to get rid of the signal in a
seismometer that's the same thing you do
with the headphones that the headphones
listen to the sounds like are coming in
they generate a sound that's the
opposite sign in the headphones and you
don't hear the outside world you only
hear the music that's on the other part
of the headphone that's how that works
it's the same idea it's an active system
that is absolutely critical to us and
that's what that was developed both
people I go and Stanford University
okay now people again I want to give
this special credit to Richard Isaacs
who is in the audience and I know he's
gonna be shirking him when his name is
mentioned but I want to tell you what he
did for us first of all he was a
first-class scientist in this business
to begin with then he wrote a paper
quite early in in the sixties where he
showed a thing that was very
controversial at the time that
gravitational waves actually carried
energy away from a source that was
heavily debated a lot of people thought
it was just a coordinate problem but he
showed there was actually energy leaving
a gravitational wave source and here is
and what he did he became the discipline
chief for gravity at the NSF and he
convinced his boss Margera Marcel Barden
at this crazy idea that we all had
really had merit and he did it at a time
when it was not so easy to do that we
didn't have the technology in hand and
we didn't know what sources were gonna
see and he had to sell this idea to his
boss and he did a magnificent job of it
then he sold the whole agency on this
okay and that's something which is
spectacular without him this would not
have worked and these are some of the
people who were influenced by that and I
want to say something special about
these are directors of the NSF which
were critical to our development rich
Isaacson was actually deeply mixed up
with Eric block with his boss and Eric
block was an engineer and and I the same
thing happened at MIT the engineers were
the first to recognize and then at MIT
that this might have some value the
electrical engineers around me it wasn't
so much the physicist and so he had the
idea that this was exactly the right
thing for the NSF to get into something
very risky but had a tremendous payoff
and so Eric block pushed it and then
when things really began to happen and
there were people who didn't like the
idea that LIGO was beginning to use
money from the NSF there were people in
the Astronomy community that actually
resisted it you can read the newspapers
as well as I
and Walter Massey who was head at that
time a little later actually told these
people who were very influential no no
we're gonna do this because it's the
right thing for the country it's the
right thing for the NSF and it was quite
a subtle and he was a magnificent person
for doing that and then to make it all
happen to the head of the NSF at that
time and this is in Barry's it was Neil
Lane and Neil Lane helped the NSF figure
out how to go to Congress and say look
the NSF needs a line item for big
projects that hadn't done big projects
before but that's what we need to do and
so there was something new invented and
that's how you get money you don't go to
Congress complaining you never go to
Congress and complaining stop this and
give it to us that's the wrong way to do
it
what you do is here is a good idea find
it you try to fund this and the idea was
the NSF has all his science we sometimes
need to build big projects and we and
and we need big chunks of money
periodically and that's still in the NSF
budget line and Neil Lane was absolutely
critical in doing that and now last
slide is this is when the project as far
as I'm concerned actually got started
because then enough people were brought
in you had finally we had somebody who
understood that it took more than us as
a skunkworks to make things happen Barry
came we were lucky that Barry came
partly because an unlock of the high
energy physicist the superconducting
supercollider got killed by I think was
quite clear it was Clinton I killed it
huh and he brought Gary Sanders who's in
the audience who would as a project
manager who was a superb project manager
he then hired more people thank God he
hired Albert Lazzarini who was also in
the audience and Dennis Coyne as a chief
engineer and he has been with the
project for a long long time he's now
doing something very interesting
different in this and what what's
happened is that Stan Whitman was
brought back from industry though it was
already under Robbie but he really was
made and became sort of the chief
scientist of legal and I meant done
thank you very much
[Music]
okay thank you very much everyone having
a chance to come up later also thank you
[Applause]